what's up everyone we're back with a
lens review that i think a lot of you
are going to be very very interested in
if you've used the g1 version like we
have your gig culture for a number of
months you're going to really like the
g2 as a matter of fact i've been testing
this out for the past couple weeks and
the image quality video and photography
has really impressed me it is just uh
this is just a beast man here it is the
all new 2875 di3 vxd g2 in the house
let's talk about it
like all my reviews i'm not paid or
sponsored unless i tell you guys and i
am not for this video but big thanks to
tamron singapore for providing the lens
for this review but it does go back to
them unfortunately because i've enjoyed
using this lens a lot you know it's nice
to use really great performing lenses
that are just workhorse lenses that get
the job done and you don't need to think
twice about them if they're focusing
well if the sharpness is there if
there's any issues with it it just works
and that's what i like to use this lens
for i've been using it for a number of
videos here on geek culture you've
probably seen a lot a few of them over
the past couple weeks and also on my own
personal channel and every time i've
used it i've gotten a comment one way or
the other commenting on the image
quality how sharp it is and how good it
looks they're like what camera using
what system what's your setup and i'm
like look i mean i'm testing out this
new lens by tamron and it's really good
and it's been this lens this has been
the lens i've been using for the past
couple weeks primarily on a lot of
videos now this video that i'm actually
filming on just in case you're wondering
is the tamron 35 to 150 up to 2.8 i it's
just a fantastic
sort of prime zoom lens from tamron i'm
going to be doing a review on this as
well that is just
it's on another level it's really really
good i mean this could be the one lens
is all you need for a as a wedding
photographer an events photographer but
we'll talk about that when i get to that
video having said that for a lot of you
out there i know you don't have time to
watch this entire video so i'm going to
give you the concise points of this
review right here but please subscribe
and like this uh video does help us out
a lot with that it is a bitingly sharp
lens it is fantastic in terms of
autofocusing speed uh again that great
2875 vocal range is ideal for
videographers out there event
photographers wedding photographers this
is a workhorse lens it is better built
than the previous g1 version and it's
pretty much the same size as the version
before that even though it has more
glass inside of it the usbc port on this
is also a nice added benefit you can
update the firmware inside of this you
can customize the focusing points a and
b focusing points and sort of do rack
focusing if you need to do that you can
also customize the function buttons on
this so that added benefit of
customization is a welcomed addition to
that welcome customization is a welcome
edition from tamron on this uh
build quality better as i mentioned
before made in japan it's not made in
another country it is made in japan
tamron considers this one of their
flagship lenses and you know what
having used it i can see why they do so
there's been no issues at all using this
lens it's been one of my favorite sony
e-mount third-party lenses i've used in
the last six to eight months overall now
in terms of the internals the g1 had 15
elements in 12 groups this has 17
elements in 15 groups now the diameter
of this lens is slightly wider coming in
at 75.8 millimeters around so it's a
little bit girthier than the g1 but of
course you got more glass inside so you
need some room to fit it right the
weight is roughly the same coming in at
540 grams so it's not an ultra light
lens but it's not a heavy lens either
and the length is pretty much exactly
the same at 4.6 inches or 117.6
millimeters um the mft charts are
you know
they're fantastic if you want to get
into all that you can the close focusing
on this at 28 millimeters is 0.18 meters
and at uh 75 is 0.38 meters so it's even
closer than the previous g1 version in
that regard i mean the only difference
you're going to notice when picking up
this lens to be honest with you is the
better build quality was which was
something i noticed as soon as i took it
out of the box and the diameter of
course is it's slightly wider but that's
it besides that
it feels really really good tamron has
done a fantastic job with this they know
this is their flagship lens they're
putting all the bells and whistles
inside of this thing and it's showing
through the image quality through and
through i really just um
you know what i'm gonna shut my mouth
right now
we're gonna show you some samples let
you be the deciding factor if this lens
is the right one for you here you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
meg
uh
[Music]
so as you can tell from the sample
footage photo and video this is a
fantastic lens it's sharp wide open it's
sharp stop down it's great for video
it's great for photography if you need
one lens to have in your kit if you
don't have a 20 uh 24 70 and you're okay
okay with the 2875 is it a little bit of
a you know different focal range but if
you're okay with this and you're okay
with a third-party lens because some
people are not this is one to definitely
consider from tamron i just don't have a
complaint with it folks i really don't
and um
i know this might sound like a paid
video but it's not it's just that the
lens is that good tamron has been doing
some really good class over the past
number of months tamron has been doing
some really great glass over the past
few months and this 2875 is right up
there with them even this 35 150 that
i'm recording on right now
it's a it's a great lens i mean that
video is coming up very soon as well
right after this and
i got no complaints guys i really don't
i think this is a fantastic time for
lenses fantastic time for cameras and uh
you know one thing that i like about
tamron is while you might not get
some of the features that of course a
native sony lens will give you
out of the gate you know if you're on a
budget or if you're just looking to save
some money here and there
this is a great option to get in your
camera bag and you're not going to miss
a beat my personal opinion so those are
my thoughts on the all new 2875 2.8 di3
vxd g2 lens let me know your thoughts in
the comments section below is this a
lens you're looking to pick up any
questions you have let me know i'll try
to answer them for you with that once
again if you like this video like
subscribe to the channel we got a lot of
great content coming up follow us on
facebook take care stay safe and i'll
chat to you soon bye
you